cynicism is often confused for insight
which is sad to see
and optimism is confused for
naivete yes yes like you don't yes
you're blinded
by your maybe your privilege or whatever
you're blinded by something but you're
certainly blind and that's a
that's sad that's sad to see because it
seems like the optimists are the ones
that create the
the
our future they're the ones that build
in order to build the crazy thing you
have to be optimistic you have to be
either stupid or
uh excited or passionate or
mad enough to actually believe that it
can be built and those are the people
that built it my favorite quote of all
time is from star wars episode 8 uh
which i know everyone hate hates do you
like star wars episode 8 uh no i
yeah probably i would say would probably
hate it yeah
i don't i don't have strong feelings
about it let me backtrack i don't want
strong feelings about star wars i'm a
tolkien person i'm not i'm i'm more i'm
more into dragons than orcs okay augers
and yeah i mean tolkien forever
i really want to have one more son and
call him i thought tau techno tolkien
would be cool
it's a lot of teas i like it yeah and
well and tau is six two eight two pi
yeah
yeah um yeah and then techno is
obviously the best genre of music but
also like technocracy sounds really good
yeah that's right and techno tolkien
um
but uh uh star wars episode eight um
i know a lot of people have issues with
it personally for on the record i think
it's the best uh star wars film um
uh
starting trouble today yeah so what uh
and uh but uh don't kill what you hate
save what you love don't kill what you
hate don't kill what you hate save what
you love and i think we're in a society
right now we're in a diagnosis mode
we're just diagnosing and diagnosing and
diagnosing and we're we're trying to
kill what we hate and we're not trying
to save what we love enough and it's um
there's this buck mr fuller quote which
i'm going to butcher because i don't
remember it correctly but it's it go
it's something along the lines of um
uh
don't
like
try to destroy the old
bad models render them obsolete
with better models
you know
maybe we don't need to destroy the oil
industry maybe we just create a new
great new battery technology and
sustainable transport and just make it
economically unreasonable to still
continue to rely on fossil fuels
you know
um it's like it's like don't don't kill
it you hate say what you love like make
new things and just render the old
things
unusable you know it's like if the
college debt is so bad
like and and universities are so
expensive like in this like i feel like
education is becoming obsolete you know
i feel like we could completely
revolutionize education and we could
make it free and it's like you look at
jstor and like you have to pay to get
all the studies and everything like what
if we created a dow that like bought
jstor or we created a dao that was
funding studies and all and those
studies were open so like or free for
everyone and like like what if we just
open sourced educate education and
decentralized education and made it free
and like um all research was on the
internet and like all the
um
outcomes of studies are on the internet
and
uh you know
like
and no one has student debt and um you
just take tests when you apply for a job
and if you're qualified
then you can work there
i'm just just like no this is i don't
know how anything works i'm just
randomly ranting but
um i like the humility um you you got to
think from just basic first principles
like what what is the problem what's
broken what are some ideas that's it and
get excited about those ideas and share
your excitement and uh don't tear each
other down like
it's just when you kill things you often
end up killing yourself like war
war is not a one-sided like you're not
going to go in and just kill them like
you're going to get stabbed it's like
and and i think when i talk about this
nexus point of um
that we're in this point in society
where we're switching to intelligent
design i think part of our switch to
intelligent design is that we need to
choose non-violence and we need to like
i think we can choose to
start i don't think we can eradicate
violence from our species um because i
think
we need it a little bit but i think we
can choose to really reorient our
primitive
brains that are fighting over scarcity
and fight and and um
either so attack oriented and and move
into we can optimize for creativity and
building
yeah it's interesting to think how that
happens so some of it is just education
some of it is
living life and introspecting your own
mind and trying to
live up to the better angels of your
nature for each one of us
all those kinds of things at scale
that's how we can sort of um start to
minimize the amount of destructive uh
war
in our world and that that's to me
probably you're the same technologies
it's a really promising way to do that
like social media should be a really
promising way to do that it's a way to
reconnect i you know for the most part i
really enjoy social media i just ignore
all the negative stuff i don't engage
with any of the negative stuff
just not even like
by blocking or any of that kind of stuff
but just not letting it enter my mind
like just like uh when somebody says
something negative
i see it
i immediately think positive thoughts
about them and i just forget they exist
after that just move on because like
that negative energy if i return the
negative energy they're going to get
they're going to get excited in a
negative way right back and it's just
this kind of vicious cycle
um but you would think technology would
assist us in this process of letting go
of not taking things personally of not
engaging the negativity but
unfortunately social media
profits from the negativity so the
current models i mean social media is
like a gun like you should take
a course before you you use it like like
it's like it's true this this is what i
mean like when i say reprogram the human
computer like in school you should learn
about how social media optimizes to you
know raise your cortisol levels and and
make you angry and crazy and stressed
and like you should learn how to have
hygiene about how you use social media
um
but
so you can yeah choose not to focus on
the negative stuff but um
i don't know i'm not sure social media
should
i guess it should exist i'm not sure
i mean we're in the messy it's the
experimental phase we're like we're
going to the early days i don't even
know when you say social media i don't
know what that even means we're in the
very early days i think social media is
just basic human connection in the
digital realm and that
i think it should exist but there's so
many ways to do it in a bad way there's
so many ways to do it in a good way
there's all discussions of all the same
human rights we talk about freedom of
speech we talk about sort of violence in
the space of digital media we we talk
about hate speech we talk about all
these things that we had to figure out
back in the day with in the physical
space we're not figuring out in the in
the digital space and it's like baby
baby stages when the printing press came
out it was like pure chaos for a minute
you know it's like it's like when you
inject when there's a massive
information injection into the into the
general population um
there's just gonna be
i like i feel like the printing press i
i don't have the years but it was like
printing press came out [ __ ] got really
[ __ ] bad for a minute but then we got
in the enlightenment
and so it's like i think we're in this
is like a
the second coming of the printing press
we're probably gonna have some shitty
times for a minute um and then we're
gonna have recalibrate to have a better
understanding of how we consume media
and how we
deliver media
you